if members who would understand what
it's like to be a Muslim living in this
country when we're facing comments made
by people like mr. Trump where people
take on bald what he's seeing is being
genuine concerns about the whole of
those of us who practice the Muslim
faith it's a very uncomfortable place to
be in
Donald J Trump is calling for a total
and complete shutdown of Muslims
entering the United States until our
country's representatives can figure out
what the hell is going on
in my islam and the Quran that I
understand in suraíh 41 of verse 34 what
it teaches means isn't word-for-word
this is what I take from my Quran is
that goodness is better than evil if
someone does bad you do good in return
this motion is actually embarrassing to
the UK and makes us look intolerant and
totalitarian and i feel we should almost
apologize to the people of the United
States I draw the line freedom of speech
when it actually imports violent
ideology which is what i feel is
happening the legislation in place is to
protect the public and protect the
people of Britain lots of my
constituents would agree with what
Donald Trump said whether I like that or
not does she think that they should be
expelled from the country as a result of
their views Donald Trump is a fool he is
free to be a fool he is not free to be a
dangerous full on our shores now while I
think this man is crazy well I think
this man has no valid points to make I
will not be the one to silence his voice
you